pouvez-vous me presser voici la réalité que
nous allons tous mourir tout le monde debout dans
cette pièce va mourir un jour
et c'est bien d'avoir un peu son
mot à dire sur la façon dont je veux m'assurer qu'elle
sait ce que nous avons exploré  toutes les
options tous les jours les gens qui sont
attachés en permanence aux machines
mon souci est que nous allons causer plus de
souffrance sans probablement bénéficier
des autres approches laissez-la passer
naturellement si vous avez envie de meurtre pour lui
retirer le maintien de la vie alors j'ai dû prendre
la décision pour  moi-même ne m'a pas
enlevé et si j'étais tout seul alors c'est
bien c'est Dieu amen comment vous
sentiriez-vous si vous ne vous amélioriez pas avec un
appareil respiratoire bon je ne veux pas
être honnête c'est une décision mais je ne  Je ne
veux pas le voir partir, nous allons
vous soutenir à travers cela,
elle ne se réveillera pas de
manière significative en sachant qu'à un moment donné, vous
devez arriver à cette réalité et maintenant c'est
ici